all right
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all right well happy Monday everyone huh
yeah so let's get into it the NAACP has
issued a formal travel warning what's
what's going on here
wait no actually really what is going on
right I think I know what the problem is
I'll I'll take care of it all right Joe
[Music]
I can't believe this they know we're
taping a show I bet this doesn't happen
during outnumbered
Xena come on we're trying to film a show
oh I apologize I thought wait hold on
take five I'm just adding a little ink
to my guns here please apologize to Greg
I thought your show got canceled I'm
always the last to know what do you
think of the
all right what do you think about it
looks good they look pretty wicked I
gotta go
she's got some guns on her Joe yeah yeah
all right all right back to the news I
think where am I okay the NAACP has
issued a formal travel advisory for the
State of Florida and why you ask is it
the weather the crime is it meth
addicted iguanas falling from the sky I
wish
I'd save so much on meals and drugs
no it's because if you go to Florida you
might just stay there and that can't
happen
they say quote Governor Ron DeSantis
aggressive attempts to erase black
history and restrict diversity equity
and inclusion programs in Florida skills
that's the reason
all right first it's not true black
history is being taught but the rest of
It's actually kind of a compliment I
mean accusing Florida of restricting Dei
programs that's a accusing me of
restricting committee chlamydia
chlamydia
so glad I can't pronounce it but you
should thank me because the only Equity
diversity creates is ensuring that all
races are illiterate but they claim
there's not enough diversity and that's
a threat to your physical health
without evidence at all but it's weird
the NAACP does a travel advisory I do
love it though when they report on ski
conditions
but you know maybe stay in your lane on
this so I don't go to Jiffy Lube for
their take on no cash bail
so before I criticize the naac NAACP I
should point out that I'm not black
but unlike some late night hosts I won't
pretend to be either
so here's the rest of the advisory quote
Florida is openly hostile toward African
Americans people of color and lgbtq plus
individuals before traveling to Florida
please understand that the state
devalues and marginalizes the
contributions of and the challenges
faced by African Americans and other
communities of color
so openly hostile what does that even
mean what do white people just spring
out from behind bushes and scream we
love khakis
it's true we do but where's the proof I
mean have you been to Miami it's hardly
the cast of Friends
and their tourism industry is thriving
over 37 million people have visited the
state so far this year and I'm pretty
sure they weren't all white were they I
mean some of them even look like this
he was there and they definitely weren't
all straight if Key West got any gear
the airport would be in a Pottery Barn
so more people moved to Florida in 2022
than any other state and they're not
just going to Disney World to see Mickey
transition into many they're sticking
around and why while it's turning red
it's Freer and it's good for everyone
contrast that with democrat-run States
like California New York and Illinois
which had the largest net domestic out
migration in that same time period I
haven't seen that many people run
screaming since killmead removed his
shirt at the gym
don't want to live in the mess they
created you know they may be morons but
they're not stupid
even Gavin Newsom went to Florida and we
could tell because we followed the trail
of hair gel
but again what is exactly happening to
black people who travel to Florida the
naacp's dire warnings doesn't say
perhaps because nothing is happening
except good things and at a state that's
exploding red you can't have that so you
need to lie one that the media gobbles
up the fact is this is a stunt that
offers no helpful advice because it's
not meant to president Derek Johnson
revealed that this advisory is really
about getting people they don't like out
of office this problem is a result of an
election it would only be fixed as a
result of the election so we are
preparing now for future elections not
only against Governor DeSantis but other
policy makers who hold this point of
view if we don't stop this trend now we
will not have an American that's
recognizable five years from now yeah
it's all going to be gone
so yeah it's a stunt and it would remain
a harmless one if it's phony warning
doesn't take up space for real ones you
know like for states where crimes insane
and inflation drains your savings see
unlike them runs cities Florida isn't
experiencing an actual crime epidemic
which explains how threats are not
defined as being misgendered and you're
being told that your ideas are
ridiculous and historical facts are
wrong but the only true threat to blacks
isn't Florida laws it's crime and it's
inflation two things the Dems can create
out of thin air and it's a threat to all
of us and that's the real fear that the
left worries about now that their
disastrous social and economic policies
might in fact unite every person of
different Creeds and colors against
their own desire to create a Marxist
dystopia so you need to create a new
amorphous threat that kind that doesn't
show up in crime stats or in morgues so
the NAACP is lying to blacks but for a
reason they don't want them to catch on
that Florida is a great state for all
kinds of people especially those who
don't see themselves as victims
[Applause]
he refuses to examine my feet
philosopher Peter bagozian
she's a Communications whiz in the
election Biz communications director at
Never Back Down pack Aaron perini
[Applause]
he's the funniest guy who was already in
the building comedian Joe Mackey
and she's like a bowl of chili Kinda hot
that causes gas Fox News contributor
captive
all right Peter was this a clever little
prank by the NAACP or was it kind of
cloying and desperate what do you see it
uh it's interesting you know the the
head of the NAACP lives in Tampa right
I mean how did how dangerous could it
possibly be and that's so true
yeah
so what else
no so I I do think that the that the
landscape has become so polarized that
instead of being honest about the
problem as you mentioned in your
monologue about the number one uh the
number one reason for for uh the number
one reason for violence among dead black
males among black males is the homicide
by other black males right and we're not
willing to be honest about the problem
and the consequence of that is if you're
not honest about the problem that you
can never solve it right and so it's
this should not be a political issue
this is an American issue yeah and
that's one of the things that we're
facing in the polarization yeah I feel
like they're they have to create a lie
because the solution doesn't include a
lot of these activists right because
they don't have the solution they never
have well it's not it's not politically
correct just to talk about facts and
statistics again as you said in your
monologue yeah we want to side skirt the
whole issue of what the facts are and go
to people's lived experiences yeah
speaking of lived experiences Joe you
have none
um
do you have you ever been to Florida it
said State down south many times Greg
including when we rocked it at the
Patriot Awards earlier this year oh we
rocked it didn't we we I rocked it yeah
I don't think I rocked it you've rocked
it a little bit and I'm not just saying
that because you're my boss and you'll
fire me if I don't but this reminds me
of like when someone makes a personal ad
and instead of using their photo they
use Pete haggs's photo right because
what's going to happen is people are
going to go to Florida and they're going
to be like well every ethnicity has
their own all-you-can-eat buffet it's
pretty fair for everybody there and what
they're doing is gambling on their
reputation and gambling on your
reputation that's like a married couple
that has an affair I've seen it so many
times those husbands are not going to
forgive their wives
yeah
what I love that yeah it went over my
head but now I'm understanding it Aaron
um
why do you think they did this is it
just all about DeSantis trying to get
because he's going to declare is that
the reason absolutely there has been a
media narrative that has gone after the
governor because he's really unafraid of
fights and this is just one of them
right right you saw it with the don't
say gay bill when it comes to stepping
up and stepping in and fighting against
indoctrination Governor DeSantis has
really LED on that and he's unafraid he
really doesn't stop until he wins so
that's what you see there and to your
point about the head living in Tampa
five members of the board went to
Florida from the NAACP if they really
find it to be such a threatening place
to be then they shouldn't vacation there
but again this isn't about an actual
policy position this is about them
making noise and you continue to see the
media grab at it and say yes this is the
problem when it's not the problem is
they don't like the governor because
he's not afraid to say hey you know what
you shouldn't indoctrinate children you
shouldn't indoctrinate in schools like
that and so we're not in Florida we're
going to make sure that you don't and
that's what you saw and I'm sorry that
they still enjoy flirty even if the
NAACP says you shouldn't yeah I don't
think anybody is taking it it's not even
in the top 10 it's not even in the top
list of states in which block on black
violence is highest right and so the
consequence of that is you'll have more
Young dead black men but they haven't
issued travel advisories against other
states yeah they haven't said anything
that's pure politics it's political but
the consequence of that politics is that
people die right so it's not a joke and
it's not a game people will die because
of this yeah you know they Florida is
highest on hot senior on senior action
at the village
right cat
and uh I believe that is true it is true
we looked at the you and I looked at the
data and it was surprising yeah yes
where do you fall on this do you find
that this might be the the kind of the
left-wing mirror of like us telling
people to get out of New York and get
out like when we talk about states and
their crime problem they're they flip it
they go well you have a you have a a
social problem you're racist
see I like I I don't care I would go
live in a state where there was like a
press briefing that verbally abused me
every single day if it meant that I
didn't get my income tax taken yeah yeah
like yeah I would put up with a lot I
don't like a lot of the stuff that Ron
DeSantis has been doing with like the
stop woke act and those sorts of things
just because I love the First Amendment
a lot and I think that it's a dangerous
precedent to be saying that entire ideas
um are should be banned even when
they're as dumb as some of these ideas
quite honestly diversity training it's
not just that there's no no proof that
it saves lives there's actually no proof
it does anything right there's actually
multiple studies that say it actually
makes things worse than they already are
and we still have it in every
corporation we'll have it everywhere but
it does it pits people against each
other in businesses it introduces really
disturbing kind of like I don't know a
politics of Envy wherever you go and so
when you're like you people suddenly
develop a suspicion towards other
co-workers or just other students
because they think well if they don't
look like me what do they think about me
yeah name the biggest jerk that you've
ever encountered in your life they've
probably been to diversity training yes
everybody has at this point and so I
yeah uh it's one of the dumbest things
ever but what are you gonna do so that's
what life is too yeah there you go well
I'm glad you ended it on that note if I
may yeah the reason that people like
Chris roof on others want to ban it is
because you have a choice of free speech
or diversity boards the diversity boards
are directly against any kind of free
speech so it's not that you're Banning
an idea it's that you're Banning a
mechanism that prevents people from
speaking openly and honestly that's the
impetus behind the the bills desantises
bill to in your face cat I
foreign
I agree with you but I also disagree
that the government should be making
laws about speech I I forgive you but
this isn't a debate show
it's not
well it could be what do you think Joe
look I just thought it was very
interesting that he said uh the country
is going to be unrecognizable in five
years and he might be right if Joe Biden
gets reelected
that note
[Applause]
Criminal
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else